[Aplausos]
en junio isabel segunda apareció en el
balcón del palacio de buckingham con
motivo de su jubileo la multitud coreó
el himno nacional dios salve a la reina'
[Música]
a partir de ahora la letra del himno
será dios salve al rey la denominación
de las tradiciones reales también
cambiará ya no se hablará de la guardia
de la reina sino de la guardia del rey
el rostro de carlos tercero empezará a
aparecer en la moneda británica
actualmente circulan 4500 millones de
billetes con el retrato de la reina por
un valor total de 80 mil millones de
libras los billetes serán sustituidos en
menos de dos años otros países de la
commonwealth también tendrán que cambiar
su moneda como nueva zelanda canadá
australia y varias naciones del caribe
todo lo que muestra la insignia la reina
isabel segunda como reina cambiará como
los sellos y los 100.000 buzones del
país pero también en los edificios
oficiales y los uniformes de las fuerzas
armadas y policiales
los pasaportes británicos entregados en
nombre de la reina también tendrán que
ser actualizados muchos otros artículos
de la vida cotidiana británica cambiarán
por primera vez en 70 años incluyendo
tazas platos y recuerdos miles de
productos creados a su imagen también
mostrarán la cara del nuevo monarca